hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
Humphrey we just got back home from
watching it chapter 2 immediately
hopping into this review I know that
it's chapter 1 is like the
highest-grossing horror movie horror
films an all-timer science and horror
opening or simple we'll talk about it
it's a great film there's a lot of hype
going into this John and I are married
to the first one as strongly as like
other people are I really liked it a lot
I saw it that one time when we went
together
yeah and I've never seen it again since
I did see the miniseries never read the
book you know I was like yeah I've got
my expectations a little bit tambour
because in the miniseries I didn't care
for the adult portion one thing that I
really wanted this movie to do good at
and I know you haven't seen it the
miniseries so you can't say this I
wanted the adult version of the movie to
be better than the miniseries and it
certainly is it's so much better it is
perfectly cast they got actors that I
only look like them just the performers
in general are awesome they are they are
awesome it's a great ensemble to me the
standouts I'm sure a lot of people have
already said this that Bill Hader as
Ritchie he is wonderful in the role like
he really he's really funny but there's
a lot of nuance to his performance
beyond being the like the most standout
performer he's also the best written
character in this movie the characters
when you meet them now don't get a whole
lot of development and yeah Ritchie and
then Eddie played by James Ransone they
both get arguably the most current day
development and so there's more to latch
onto with those characters I do think
that there are some great visuals in
here I feel like any machete and team
really conjured up a lot haha drink I
feel like Andy was shitty in team really
thought of you know a lot of cool
sequences or what they can do a little
bit different or things imaginative
horror
yeah maybe things they couldn't even do
in the first one that they decided to
bring to here like a wide variety of
creatures that stem from practical
effects to performers and makeup to just
flat-out CGI and there's some pretty
good CGI in here too apparently those
kids are da
so yeah your old flashbacks in some new
flashbacks and you know just Finn wolf
Hart's head just is a different show up
I think there's some really cool visuals
in here the thing is when I was walking
out of this room you were talking the
car ride back I realized that it order
for me to tell if I liked this movie I
would need to bring a notebook with me
yeah you gotta write down a list of pros
and cons it's literally I would need a
tally when I'm bored and when I like
something that's going on because that
was majority of my experience with this
film I was either like not that
interested or just plain and simple like
kind of checking out or bore to oh wow
like sometimes it was in within the same
scene would not be wouldn't care what's
going on I'm like come on whatever I get
it - Oh was actual awesome sometimes
ever get a little cynical about it
because every once in a while it seemed
like to make it interesting or engaging
sometimes the scare stuffs felt like
random they didn't integrate into the
plot quite as naturally as it did the
first time to me no like I said we are
not that married to the first one I
really like that one and what I remember
from that film was when it was not going
for scares I was still very engaged that
I I felt the whole ensemble the whole
losers Club
I thought the heart was great and I
thought the humor was consistent and
really funny and and don't get me wrong
there are times I laughed pretty hard
there's a few scenes in here that I
could think of right now that really
made me laugh there are some jokes or
just kind of out of place or weird yeah
for Mia this is the definition of a
mixed bag and I honestly don't maybe by
the time we're done filming I can tell
if I like this movie or not cuz right
now I just I can't tell if I actually
like this film because it actually some
even though I think it's better than the
miniseries it's to me it still suffers
from a lot of the issues that I had with
the miniseries because this takes place
27 years later you're checking in with
these guys as adults I really on in the
film you see where they're at at this
point in life and then when they get
called back to dari because a Mike
played by Isaiah Mustafa he still lives
in dari
he thinks Pennywise
is back in town as the rest of the cast
comes together you know you start seeing
like oh they actually don't remember
jack about what went on and so most of
this movie is dedicated to remembering
pretty much the first movie or
additional flashbacks the thing with a
lot of these flashbacks while it's cool
to see the kids return so much of those
flashbacks I didn't feel were ultimately
necessary in fact they actually made the
adults less interesting for so much of
the film when they first unite I felt
the ensemble I'm like oh wow they did it
the whole ensemble is here but as the
movie went on I started feeling less for
the ensemble and started really only
caring about Bill Hader and Jay Ryan and
James McAvoy when he's being intense and
that's pretty much where I landed with
the performances and no one suddenly
started sucking in the film it's just
they were the ones I ended up caring for
where is it the first one I remember
really caring about everyone who was
there I felt some people could have been
serviced a little bit more but I still
cared about the group this film is weird
to me because it is not enough of a film
to really commit as hard as it arguably
should for the amount of character they
want to throw at you because it's trying
to also be a blockbuster horror movie
basically so we can't get too deep down
that rabbit hole and what you end up
with is a lot of moments that serve to
develop characters or whatever but yeah
the film to me especially got hampered
basically by the past and by nostalgia
and by the love I think that a lot of
people just generally have for that
first movie yeah because you could have
spent a lot of time endearing us to
adult characters and remembering these
things through their adult eyes versus
just literally having kind of a Greatest
Hits medley of that first yeah plus
there are a few extras there were so
many moments where I'm like you could
still do the whole trying to rediscover
the past and rediscover who you were as
children but sometimes I think it
actually that phrase less is more kind
of comes back there are scenes I can
think of that would have been more
powerful if you were just watching the
adults kind of remember just through
like their dialogue or expression as
opposed to let's check back in with the
actual flashback of the kids let's have
the kid and then we'll come back to the
adult at the yang going yeah
and then we'll cut to the other adult
now because there's a big portion of
this movie where they're all on their
own they have to remember on their own
you know oh yeah and that's another
thing about the pacing of the movie and
the shape of the movie overall because
this has a very British plot to me or
pace to me and part of that is because
especially in the first half you have
these moments that inevitably have to
play out five or six different times so
that you can see every different person
in the ensemble's little moment with
whatever plot piece were with and then
you know Mike Hamlin comes back every
now and again to move the play hung the
movie's clunky and I think what there
helps the the clunkiness of the film and
EMU yeti-like mastered cool transitions
there's so much back to solve for with
how many just like clever like here's a
wiper here's like yeah I could see that
I mean I feel like yeah very
yes yeah that's a cool transition hey
which I felt they really needed in order
to make the amount of cutting around as
so many different things that were going
on from my understanding that's how it
is in the book the adults are trying to
remember blah blah blah the miniseries
does it I guess I had this expectation
going in like I don't have this
expectation of it one is so great this
movie better be as good that's not at
all what I expected and the only
expectation I actually had alright I get
it they did it chapter one were there
kids then we could do it chapter two
where you get the adults so let's get to
know them as adults I really felt like I
didn't really get to know them as adults
most of them so much of it is just
dedicated to who they were in the past
and just trying to remember if you
really look at the actions they have to
do when going up against it going up
against penny wise it's pretty much the
same thing like yeah there are some
added nuances to what they inevitably
have to do here but yeah it leaves you
with the air left me with a very just
impersonal feeling overall which is a
big bummer and not that they're similar
very in very many ways but I felt kind
of like I did with the Hobbit world I
was like oh so much great casting like
I'm really excited to see these actors
kind of get lost in a big journey of
different
things that are happening and so I feel
like the performances and some of the
context behind them are affecting but
one thing that was hugely missing from
this movie for me that was everyone's
favorite part of the first one is an
ensemble vibe or you know like some kind
of energy that exists within a group
that you can endear yourself to and the
movie to me rested most of that effort
on the previous movies effort absolutely
yeah I had two thoughts that kept
popping in my head like this movie is so
in love with itself and it's so in love
with the first movie that it's
forgetting to introduce me to all these
new actors that I know are the same
character yes like you can't just count
on the fact that I like James McAvoy and
Bill Hader and whoever yeah they really
could have serviced the carrot and I
don't like I said I haven't read the
book and even if like all this does go
on in the book that doesn't mean it's
all necessary gonna translate to a
well-made film I really wasn't aware
going into this movie that this was
gonna be primarily what I had an issue
with and like it's a it's a long movie I
really felt it III like and and really
on yeah I felt it early on I'm like wow
we could have cut out so many of these
flashbacks and then I mean some of the
flashbacks are cool every once in a
while a flashback features a cool scare
sequence does it ultimately move the
movie forward no it doesn't it does not
you can kind of sum this movie up by
saying I would by saying that it has a
lot of great parts but the whole is not
necessarily the sum of its parts yes
like there are a lot of great scenes and
in fact when the movie is being a horror
movie and doing horror stuff I liked
pretty much all of that it's just how
they chose to link it together and pace
it with the characters yes and I don't
know if you notice this but we haven't
really talked about penny wise penny
wise doesn't really feel like a presence
to me in this film I've heard some
people say like it could have used more
penny wise I've heard some people say
that they think they use penny wise more
in this film to me I don't feel a loop
even even in in chapter 1 he's not in it
the whole time it's mainly in to losers
Club but at least in that movie he's a
constant looming presence and he has a
really powerful impact and here the
focus I don't think is anywhere near as
strong as the first one and I don't
think its structures anywhere near as
well told and it so I would kind of
forget
about Benny I forget about Pennywise the
clown oh yeah it doesn't actually are to
me it didn't paint a very clear picture
of the state of Derry yes present and
what penny like you know it's really to
the town or anything it makes this
situation feel very insular and isolated
to these people even though it's not I
think bill skarsgård when he's doing his
dialogue and everything he's a lot of
fun to watch he's definitely not scary
in this movie and I think the scary
stuff I mean I wasn't really scared I
think the most exciting tense stuff came
from when it wasn't Pennywise the clown
yeah technically that's all coming from
the character Pennywise but when it was
but when it wasn't you know bill
skarsgård that's when it was actually
like you know like that kind of threw me
off yeah I mean from my understanding
that is you know an aspect is like heat
it takes on a lot of forms and stuff
like that for the fun of the second half
theoretically would be that aw we don't
only see the clown and yeah I do agree
that a lot of the times the more
surprising and the more intriguing
things are those because they're new yes
give a chance for a cool new effect or
something to me if a lot of this felt
like rehash repeat revisit I felt like
it just could have focused a lot more on
who these guys are now and doing some
more overall new things I it
complimented the past and learn from the
past and I don't feel like it did yeah
some of the arcs I'm a little bit unsure
of like what exactly the are when those
scary moments are there the visuals and
there's and the performers are generally
really good the complaints really stand
out to me I couldn't help but be pulled
out I just think about why I'm like not
enjoying this movie but then sometimes
in the same scene I would end up
enjoying it and who knows maybe some
stuff might gourami
there are things about this are really
well done overall the impact I felt I
didn't feel much other than I didn't
really feel anything
unless the movie randomly made me laugh
or if there was a scare thing they were
trying to accomplish I think the overall
conclusion with Pennywise kind of
lackluster when you think about it you
know what it is the first movie had a
lot of heart and this movie's heart I
don't really feel like I just wanted
some other emotion other than just okay
when something exciting gonna happen and
I felt like the heart was there in the
last like 15 minutes of the
movie but that is two hours and 30
minutes and this movie ends I'm like oh
really whew well I'm actually really
feeling for this movie now instead of
just watching this movie yeah there's I
don't know if I would ultimately come
down on the fully negative side because
I do think that there again like every
aspect of this movie works at some point
you know even if there is a lot of very
straightforward dialogue and stuff like
eventually there are things to
appreciate in every faction of the movie
I would need Italian just thinking about
it as an overall film experience it
doesn't flow as well as the first one
and so you're gonna sit and bumpy yeah
right now am i like-a I had control the
tomato meter I would say I'm at like 45%
positive I'm like put it in a salt I
feel like this is prime for a solid 50
just like it depends on just like the
sequence of things that you liked and
everyone's gonna have yeah I mean most
of the opinions are pretty similar
breezing through their garroted tomatoes
capsules I'm like the positive and
negative capsules most of them sound
pretty much the same it just really
seems like some people's tally was a
little bit more positive
some people's was a little bit more
negative and I'm just like yeah I I
don't know I need to like digest some
stuff I don't know if I'm being too
harsh I was just we're just there we
were just there alright guys well did
you see it chapter 2 are you excited to
see it if you haven't have the reviews
been jacking you up you know what I
would love I would love it if you're one
of those people who has already made up
your mind about how you're gonna feel
about this and you haven't even seen the
movie yet and you're mad at me for my
opinion you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell and I'd like to give a patron the
day shout out to a lovely lady named
Adelia Chamberlain Adelie and I were
talking recently and I think I was
partially responsible for convincing her
to just finally have watched it chapter
1 she wants to prepare herself to go
watch it chapter 2 she's been drawn to
it that's a great piece of advice now I
didn't prepare ahead Julia if you are
you are an aspiring writer you you
currently write quite a bit right now
actually I would love to know your
opinion on this you have been
thing but kind to us nothing but just so
supportive and considerate and engaging
with almost everything we do I love you
you're amazing
you're you're a part of our losers you'd
be the Beverly and our losers yeah dude
so you're gonna write to the poem or am
i I was just hopin straight to the or
but you know what